trumpist area is one is a different
thing right like I experienced this you
know in in 2020 right I I publicly said
I was voting for Trump and I said uh you
know why did you choose to go public
with that just out of curiosity because
I'm not a right and not everyone
says who they're voting for right like
why did you feel like it's important
that you voiced this opinion I voiced I
voiced my opinion because I was very
afraid of the direction America would go
if Joe Biden became president and
and at this point I'm like 30 for 30.
right so the things that I was concerned
about wind up you know manifesting
themselves it's also too he's a it's the
problem with Joe Biden if you just want
to look from a from a public standpoint
on the world stage he's he like
something's wrong with him he has a
either a degenerative brain issue
something's wrong right and so we only
had these two people to choose from and
I I even said in an insane world I
quoted Terminator 2 I was like in an
insane world this was the same as choice
and that cost me my record deal my band
turned on turned against me the entire
uh mainstream Rock media and I was
immediate darling if you Google me you
know before that post
I've given millions of dollars away and
to Charities
um I've been sober for 14 years I was a
drug and alcohol counselor I helped
dozens and dozens of people in the music
industry get sober I've been awarded
personally year by Rock to Recovery in
Los Angeles
uh I I mean you know the list goes on
and on and on right but once that
changed it was like yeah Tommy Vex is
crazy he's a baseless conspiracy
theorist you know it was like I then I
had like an ex come out of the woodwork
and try to me too me to get a hundred
thousand dollars and I beat that case in
criminal court and then I got exonerated
she tried to take me to court again in
uh in Civil Court beat it there I was
exonerated by the judge of any
accusations of domestic violence and um
but that's not what the media posted
right they just I became the enemy yeah
and so there was there was this Trump
hysteria where people were convinced
that he was
Hitler or something right like that he
was gonna we were gonna go and all the
things that they said about him bro well
yeah they're like they're like he's
gonna get us into World War Three and uh
and now look where we are yeah they're
openly saying they want world war three
yeah yeah and I'm like you guys are
insane and I didn't I don't get an
apology right it just gets swished under
the table you know and it's like I had
massive not only tell me not only does
it get switched under the table like the
Press is extra critical of you now even
if your name comes up so it's like
because you were going against the grain
and a lot of the things that you were
talking about actually came to have it
came to pass there's the P the the metal
press is is more critical and they're
they are you know it's not like oh well
you know Tommy was right and and this
and that it's oh you know he's this bad
guy that that kid but they were wrong
well they won't do that well they're not
gonna do that because well this I mean
it's it it's other things too well they
they're building a historical record of
who you are yeah and so it starts with
one lie the next day they double down on
the LIE then in a month that lie is the
truth and they put on Wikipedia they put
it in the archives but these people the
problem with the with the the hive mind
of of this these this kind of corporate
environment is they're so afraid they're
they're false concern is so mixed up
right they're so afraid that like
Trump's going to be Hitler that they
start behaving the way the Nazis did
right like Gina Carano got canceled off
what her show yes no she got canceled
off her show and I actually misspoke
about this on Brad Lee's podcast and I
was like because she didn't put her
pronouns in her bio but the thing that
people really were pissed off is that
she had accused the far leftist as
behaving as the Nazis did during uh
pre-holocross Germany right during the
Weimar Republic or whatever and
I I I don't think that that's wrong in
the sense that and again I'm saying
pre-holocaust but it's a scary thing to
be a person and supposedly a free
country and having your platform taken
away your ability to make a living
having lies spread about you and the
Machine of the media that what they do
is it's a civil crucifixion
the thing with the Gina Carano thing not
only that but like they said they
accused her of doing something that she
didn't do like that isn't an aunt like
she didn't say anything that was
critical of Jewish people she didn't say
anything that that the Holocaust didn't
happen that like everything she said was
like look you're just treating people
badly and she made a comparison that
people could use against her is really
what it was because it it's not the
problem is is there are there are again
there are a lot of similarities to the
things that were going on like I the the
the George Floyd riots were remarkably
ident identical to the night of broken
glass right yeah right and people who
don't know history don't even know what
that means and they're like well I feel
like there are similar things happening
here and there are people who are really
you know there are certain people who
are involved who are children when it
happened the first time who we don't
speak we don't say their names who are
who are financing certain behaviors and
certain groups to do certain things that
are very reminiscent of the exact same
historical issues that went on in
pre-World War II Germany do you see what
Bill Maher said about communism no I
haven't seen that yet he was he he he
chose the other you know uh early 1900s
psychotic despots the Communists yeah
Red Guard and he talked about how and I
think I think there's a similarity
between you know what you're saying in
this he was talking about how they try
to change human nature that they they
all believe in this vision and so they
enact this cultural revolution
and then that Vision ultimately is just
everyone new socialist man but right
right right but but the end result is
they you you drum up fervor tribal rage
you tell everybody you know who the
enemy is it doesn't matter what the
ideology is ultimately it's cult
authoritarianism that results in
genocide of some sort
the question is is that is that where
we're going
there are I think that the United States
because of our and I'm gonna this is
probably gonna upset a lot of people the
United States is a unique country in the
way that our government is formed and it
is uniquely resistant to things like
totalitarianism and it's uniquely
resistant to
authoritarian impulses by a president or
one individual it's not that the U.S is
completely immune to it but our Republic
you know our Republican form of
government does insulate us from that so
I don't think that the U.S is in a
situation where it's a an immediate
danger but I do believe that there is an
entire generation possibly two of people
that are going to be coming out of uh
high schools and colleges that have
significant significant weight
significantly different ways of thinking
so they don't approach the world the way
that liberals approach the world they're
ill liberal because they're taught to be
illiberal in Paulo Fieri schools think
about where this country is going to be
in three or four generations that's the
problem absolutely but think about this
think about what the the greatest
Generation would say about all of us
here right now if they were you know 20
years old right Sheamus of Freedom Tunes
did this bit where a bunch of leftists
summoned World War II soldiers from the
past into today to help them fight the
rise of the Nazis and so they're like
you know these soldiers are like what
are we doing here and they're like the
leftists are like we need your help
Nazis are coming back and they're like
they are well we got to stop them and
then when they explained to the World
War II soldiers what they're fighting
for the soldiers are shocked that
interracial marriage is legal that gay
marriage is legal because back then it
wasn't yeah it was like segregation
still during World War II and now now
we're going backward to segregation you
know there are people that want to
segregate uh segregate schools right
right well so ultimately my point is
like the things that they thought were
unacceptable or acceptable or otherwise
back then are now by our standards
completely acceptable so with the way
things are going with young people with
these woke shows with how movies are
going that that's the track we are on
yeah where the establishment machine is
woke and crazy and it's going to get
crazier but maybe we're looking at a
four a fourth turning a straw style
generational Theory kind of thing this
could be the end where the snap happens
the crash the the fourth turning and
then 2030 2028 and Beyond or whatever
could be more post-apocalyptic or
Reconstructionist yeah I I don't know
that I have a an opinion on the fourth
turning and stuff like that I I am not
as familiar with that well it's a strong
man make good times good times make weak
men weak men make Hard Times Hard Times
make strong men so and so in the hard
times now are yes weak men made hard
made hard times and now we're in the
hard times and people are being carved
out of stone see I feel like we're
making weak men still no for sure
absolutely I think that there's a
concerted effort to continue that
process and I think that definitely as
people uh as as parents continue to
raise children that are mindful of this
of the undoc Nation that's what's going
to change things absolutely I think that
I think that there's the fact that there
is there is so I was just out in in LA
and doing all the remain stuff and I was
talking to someone that's going to
remain nameless but and they were saying
look they're like look the woke stuff
you know they're like we I don't I don't
think that people are gonna be into it
and I think that people are over it et
cetera et cetera and I'm like yeah but
the reason that people are aware of it
and that they're they're concerned with
it is because they found out about it
through probably through the the uh
cameras and classes during covet and
stuff like that and remote learning and
stuff but it took people finding out and
then
people actually pushing back to get to
the point where like he feels
comfortable saying I think people are
over the wokeness thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time